Liz asks any tips on how to make an
unknown hashtag like # mommy energy
popular and
well-known Liz first of all I love that
name wife's name sister's name uh second
of all it makes me sad Liz that uh that
I have to attack you in a good way uh
with the following question so everybody
pour yourself a little bit of Sherry uh
grab your cigars if you like that kind
of thing because this is a long- winded
answer one of the things I thought about
over the weekend is to give some real
meat on the bones on some of these
answers you're going to have your pie or
cake questions which I love by the way
and I want more of those by the way so
ding those up ding those up the hell
does that mean I also want to give long-
winded answers to when they deserve them
and Liz I appreciate you because you
asked a question that a lot of people
are focusing on and I want to put some
real girth behind it and so here we go
Liz first question back to you little
pingpong action here is why do you want
it to Trend so you get something to
Trend and the interesting thing is as we
all know trending hashtags hashtags in
general are actually not very ownable
right if you create a hashtag anybody in
the Twitter universe can jump along and
use that hashtag more importantly when
hashtags you know Trend we've seen a lot
of spam people jump in and use that
hashtag in their tweet to create spam to
create porn you know the funny thing is
is I always ask why so my question to
you is why Steve throw it out here you
can be part of this question what's the
hashtag hash mommy energy you know uh by
the way uh speaking of mommy energy I
spoke with Steve's mom on Twitter this
weekend and she mentioned that she liked
Steve on camera so that was a little
mommy energy you know Liz the real
question is why would you want Mommy
energy to Trend do you feel that you
then benefit from it do you not realize
that every mommy blogger anybody selling
products to mommies anybody authoring
mommy books can jump in use that hashtag
there is no ownership there's limited
upside you know the only reason I use
the ask ARB hashtag is to find the
questions easier it's a utility it is
not a marketing engine to take me to the
next level because I know it's so unable
and so that is really the question to me
to everyone to who's watching which is
why would you want to own it in the
first place that's something that you
need to think about the why against any
action is really the that people are not
spending enough time on the strategy
matters